est consacrée qui nous permet de
découvrir un peintre, mais on
devrait redécouvrir avec de
nouveaux yeux.
♪ ♪ ♪
- "Paul Tex Lecor,
fils de la liberté", c'est
le titre de l'exposition qui
lui est consacré à Repentigny.
En plus de collaborer avec lui
sur scène et à la télévision,
Shirley Théroux a partagé
l'atelier de l'artiste.
SHIRLEY THÉROUX,
artiste multidisciplinaire
- Il faisait des fresques
où il rentrait 40-45 personnes;
c'était... fabuleux de voir ça,
et soudainement, il y avait
un éclat de rire incroyable.
Je lui disais : qu'est-ce qui
se passe? Fait que là, il me
disait : "Ah! Écoute, viens
voir, viens voir, viens voir."
Ses personnages prenaient
forme au fur et à mesure.
- Parfois snobées parce
qu'elles étaient considérées
comme de l'art populaire,
les toiles de Tex Lecor
valent la peine qu'on y jette
un deuxième coup d'oeil.
DANIELLE OUIMET, animatrice
- C'est ça, être peintre,
c'est d'avoir un contact
direct, direct avec
l'âme des gens et... c'est
un être... d'une luminosité
et d'une générosité;
vous le verrez, d'ailleurs,
dans chacune de ses toiles.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Né dans une famille d'artistes
et formé à l'École des
Beaux-arts, Tex Lecor a été
une vedette de la radio
et de la télévision.
Il a connu le succès comme
auteur-compositeur-interprète.
♪ - Tant qu'il me restera
quelque chose ♪
♪ Dans le frigidaire ♪
♪ Je prendrai le métro
je fermerai ma gueule ♪
♪ Puis je laisserai faire ♪
- Mais la peinture a été l'une
de ses plus grandes passions.
- Là où il était le plus
heureux, c'était dans
son atelier. Lui, il rentrait
dans son atelier et il dit :
"Shirley, je suis heureux,
c'est ça, mon bonheur."
- Indépendantiste, Tex Lecor
aimait survoler le Québec
dans son avion.
ROBERT BERNIER, commissaire
- Ça lui a permis d'aller
souvent dans la baie d'Ungava.
Il a pas cherché à caricaturer.
Il avait un grand respect
pour les Premières Nations;
là, il avait plusieurs amis.
Et là, il se fermait
et il écoutait.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Membre des peintres
de la Norditude, Tex Lecor
peignait la splendeur et les
couleurs de la Belle Province.
- Il y a beaucoup d'histoires
à l'intérieur des toiles de Tex,
il y a l'histoire du Québec,
il y a l'histoire de...
son histoire à lui, il y a
l'histoire de ses amis.
Mais surtout de son grand
patriotisme; il aimait
passionnément le Québec
et il l'a installé
dans toutes ses toiles.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Tex Lecor est mort en 2017,
mais ses peintures restent et
elles célèbrent magnifiquement
le printemps québécois qui,
chaque année, refleurit.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, R